Good thing you don't touch it anymore,
dude. What is happening?
What is happening?
If uh if your mom never did that and you don't know what Amaran's
talking about right now, you weren't loved as a child. I don't
think so. You don't get to threaten me like that. If you're going
to do that, you know, I'm sorry this. I didn't do anything to
you. You accused me of something I didn't say and you unmuted
and you said it. No, you did say it. The security camera has
your footage. Fine. But if there's no qualifier there. What do
you mean qualifier? I'll never tell you. You'll have to go find
out. Left the property. You have to go find out.
You haven't left the property. You can talk to my lawyer at this
point. You don't have one.
That's what you think. You're right. I don't have one. I have
Oh, 7 hours 52 was a time stamp.
Okay. 7 hours 52 to 8 hours. Going to the Amaranth stream. The
Amaranth stream. Let's
go. 7 hours 52 is where we are. Right around here.
All right. My part is I've tried to not give up on him for too
many years. His problem is he's insane.
I don't You know, if you want to, I can't control you, Nick.
You're the one who blew up in me.
Nick. Yeah. Okay. Sorry.
Sir, the way she said Nick there, she was like, "Nick,
Nick." I just I It connected.
I've got really bad wiring in my brain. Okay. The wiring is rusty.
So 7:36 is where we should start. Actually, we went a little
too late. A little too deep. He didn't actually. I mean, he went
hunting for it. Yep. He stopped by on his way home.
Dang. Ice cream for food. Yeah. Oh, hold on. Is he going to work
out?
Okay. So, he walks over and he's like, "Whoa, you good, fatty?
Having a little ice cream there, fatty? Trying to turn into a
cow there, fatty?" That's not a great way to start. This guy
This guy's kind of cartoonish, honestly. He's He is cartoonish.
I was saying he's so exaggerated, bro.
I haven't eaten
enough. You stare at pictures of horses all day. Do you Did you
even work out? I didn't I ate even less than you. Oh, I fell
in. Mhm.
Oh my god. It's the same slop. It's the same slop.
No, it's not even ice cream. That's got to be That's got to be
the Noki again.
Oh, you're you're right.
What? There's no Do we have to go back in the VOD and watch her
eat the bread stick? No, we won't. I'm just going to get a napkin.
We won't. We won't. We
I need bread sticks though. Where are the bread sticks?
No. Why did someone l you this time s because she eats this again?
I swear to God. Nick, bring the bread sticks. Bring the bread
sticks now. Nick, bring the bread
sticks. I don't think so.
Oh, why?
On team Nick. We're on team Nick. I'm on team Nick. This would
be
this would this might be something if I hadn't watched her eat
the bread sticks already once or twice. I It actually might be
something
gross. It's just
Monkey Boss says her fart jars smell like Olive Garden. That
is just one of the most vile comments I've ever heard in my entire
life. I
You bring that up again. I'm leaving.
Oh. Oh, really? Look at your avatar on the stream.
Let's go.
Let's go. That meeting not. Unironically, I'd wear a hat like
this in real life. Nothing for 3 months. They don't have much
money.
They don't have drug split.
Okay.
Wow, you were right. Orange Nick W. A rare I'm kidding. I'm messing
with uh it's it is literally it it's
like it's got to be like borderline white sauce. I actually don't
know how she um I don't know how she eats this stuff so often.
This is like this has to be like 3,000 calories this bowl of
food, right? Am I Am I insane?
So now you're calling her for that. I just don't I don't get
it. It's a joke. What you say next? No, don't hit me. What? I'm
just eating. Why you apologize to that? Okay.
He does have stuff is thick.
That stuff's What the hell is in that sauce that be 3,000 calories
just to go? Why you want to I don't want PLO talking about and
her having big hands so close to his mic and making me uncomfortable.
Yeah, she does got some big hands.
You cook, Kenny. It's over. I just I feel like I hate everything
about this. I just Why?
Oh, I didn't know that, Zan Kelly. And you just made it significantly
weirder. Now you please delete that message.
Next time you tap me on the shoulder, I'm going to call the cops
and try to get you thrown in jail for striking me.
okay. So, she is objectively trying to fight with him now. That
would actually work. Yay.
Good thing you don't touch me anymore.
Dude, what is happening?
What is happening?
Because I shook a game. This makes me never want to eat food
ever again.
Like this just ruins the concept of food and
Well, I don't know. Agree to disagree on that one. I guess this
is uh this is just good comedy. No, that's not not a good look
for you. Let's not talk about it. No, I'm just saying I didn't
touch you. No, I know my point was not that you touched me.
my point that you were doing that you didn't need to and there
was puppies jumping out of the gate out of fear. So that's not
a good look. Don't bring it up. I'm saying don't bring it up.
Let's not need to [__] Let's not Let's not Let's
not talk about it. You didn't You also didn't need to prevent
me from moving around my own property.
Yeah, you did. You held out your arm. What is that, dude? Let's
be honest. No. No. You want You want to be derisive? Fine. Let's
do it.
God damn it. I really thought we got through to Nick. Nick, walk
away. Nick, just walk away. She said something weird. Just walk
away.
I thought we made progress. Nick, you're supposed to walk away.
Nick, please. I didn't fix the addict in the span of 24
Yeah. No. You came You have You could have gone the other direction.
You came at me saying you literally I didn't come at you. you.
I went to the side of you. Okay, we're going to do this again.
Let's Let's go then. You're the one doing it, Dave. No, no, no.
You said I was preventing you from going anywhere on your property.
That's just not true.
I I did not say that. I said, "Why should I have any restriction
in where I go on my You can go wherever you want. Just calm down
when you come in my direction." I That's So, you held your arm
out to stop me because I didn't seem calm instead of letting
me walk by. Yeah, it's a reaction.
Got some absolutely cinema sound engineering, audio engineering
going on again from the amaran stream. Literally can't hear anything
over the TV.
It's corelling you like the officer said. Only time will tell.
It's like when a mom puts her arm up when she stops really suddenly.
It said on the passenger seat cuz it's like whoa.
If uh if your mom never did that and you don't know what Amaran's
talking about right now, you weren't loved as a child. Just letting
you know. They wanted your your your forehead to hit the dashboard.
Why are you I was telling you, why are you throwing that at people,
bro? Why are you putting that those hex's on other people? Cuz
it actually upsets me that my mom used to do that all the time.
I'd be like, "Dude, if if we actually got in an accident and
the air brake went off, you'd literally like break my nose."
I hope you know that.
Yeah, I'm sure your six-year-old aunt said that to your mom.
I guarantee. No, my mom would do that when I was like 15,
I'm sure my mom would do that now. I'm not even joking. I think
my mom would do that now.
They weren't in a car and you were just walking past there.
Oh, no. No, no. As I look at the security camera.
What? Why are you looking at me like that?
I get it. I get it. I just won't bring it up next time you have
another parking lot hand job. I guess simple.
Okay. Now, now it's like starting to get
Dude, it was real. That line right there, I'm just like, "Oh,
they're just This is what it looks like when they act now. That
actually looks like acting to me. That sounds like acting. That
wasn't even well delivered. No passion there. Nothing. The What
were you going to say,
What is this like level one
It is I Yeah, I don't know. Bring it up next time you give another
parking lot hand job. I guess
there's no way she doesn't take that bait, right?
She's got her Alfredo sauce and the chicken. Does she eat like
that, man? How the hell? What is going on, dude?
Why is she eating like she's a lizard person? It looks like she's
This is the fifth time in her entire life she's ever eaten. Ever.
First time watching Amaran. Amaranth eating is like a content
in and of itself. If she did a mukbang channel, she would actually
skyrocket to the top of Only Fans again. I'm not even joking.
No, wait. You're on to something. Mukbang channel have Yeah.
And you have Nick yapping in the background while she's eating.
Oh Jesus. That would be crazy.
Is that not just broccoli? It's chicken. I don't I'm not probably
not saying that correctly, but here. Chicken. I'll look it up
at Olive Garden. Okay. A box is hot with or a box of returning
your
child. Either way, one fits all.
I will just be your painting.
Donation coming through.
Parking lot hand job sound like a band name.
Parking lot hand job sounds like a band name. Oh wow. Thank you
for the donation, Ruben.
ribbon.
So, I can't see what the serving is, but one serving of the chicken
noki from Olive Garden is 230 calories.
Okay. That's almost It's most It's a lot of carbs. Whole lot
of
carbs. Uh, can I see? I thought you said
Sorry. This is one serving. It's not like uh it's not going to
be like one bowl. This is going to be like the smallest. It's
going to be like a/4 cup. Unironically, it's going to be like
a quarter cup. Yeah.
Yeah.
I don't think so. Wait, what's the size of one serving, dude?
Weight zero grams. Yeah, one serving. Said one serving right
there. It says per serving right there. It does say one serving.
Yes, but what is one what is a serving? It's certainly not that
tub she gets it in. There's no way. Did it not say 21 gram there?
Yeah, cuz per serving
22 gram of carbs per serving. Yeah. Uhhuh. Also, 1290 milligrams
of sodium
per serving. And you say three. You said three calories.
Not per
serving. It says one bowl, but she's only serving. Like she ate
10 servings. Okay. Maybe not 3,000. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I overshot
it. Okay, calm down.
They've muted. How long do we mute for plus the bread? Six.
True. Over a gram of salt for something that's under 200 calories
is unhinged.
unhinged. So they talk for a little bit. They talk. They talk.
They talk. They talk. They talk. Talking talking. Oh, here we
go.
Oh, you're gonna fight. You just said that you were trying to
go ham and cancel the construction. How can you say that you're
freaking out about a Oh, phone call with your safety if you're
willing to cancel construction. Muted. No, you just said you
were going to cancel construction. So, no. I can't stop giving
[__] to people. That's not true. I caught you in
the
This is like every abusive behavior we walked him through. This
is them. This is all of them at one time.
Oh, Nick, when she told me abusive behavior.
Uh, yeah. I think I basically said like when you when you escalate
from an emotional place with nothing to gain that is probably
going to be abusive, whatever you're doing that like she yells,
you yell back. She leaks something about you, you leak back.
Like it's it's bad. It's bad parking lot. No, I thought you said
it was a hand job in the parking lot. Now it's a [__]
Can't keep your sto fake story short. He only kissed you. Now
you agree it's a hand job. No, I don't agree. I will say we got
a little bit of growth in that he has not pointed out the race
of the person she was in the parking lot yet. Okay. Play. Wait,
look at him. Look at Nick. He looks so cool. Look at him. He
said I'm looking at her. Okay. Oh my god. All right. All right.
Why do you in the parking lot? I thought you said it was a hand
job in the parking lot. Now it's a [__] Can't keep
your fake story straight. Cuz he only kissed you. Now you agree
it's a hand job. No, I don't agree. I'm saying you can't keep
your fake story straight. Don't you listen to me.
First nothing happened. Then oh, he only kissed me. Oh, then
it's like my my hand in my sleeve. And I told you the sleeve
from the very beginning, but you accused me of what it looked
like. It's just not. That's what you want to think cuz you know
you're guilty of cheating on me multiple times. You're just projecting.
Physical. You're just projecting. Wait, I haven't. How do I know?
You did it behind my back and deleted emails. How would I know?
That seems kind of sus and guilty to me. So, let me get this
straight. You're going to let your chat You're going to let
chat now. I hate that I now I'm seeing like
I I'm somehow reading like acting now and I don't know what happened.
I literally can't place where this this suddenly in my head went
to like this seems actually different to me. I don't know how
to explain it. I I'll wait. We'll have to keep watching. But
now I'm like, dude, now this feels like they're playing this
up. Remember that 0%. No, I'm telling you it was 0% before. Now
it's not that it's repeating. It's that like this feels less
genuine. This feels like they're saying the same things and they're
like almost laughing at each
drive the discourse.
Huh. Started this. Remember what we said about streaming? I didn't
say what you said. That's the case. I'm welcome to cancel it
now. You can't cancel. Okay, never mind. Now, now I'm not getting
now. I'm not getting acting at all. I don't know what it was.
I shouldn't have said anything. Acting. No. No. Now I'm getting
that Nick is actually people to know it's not coming back now.
No. Did you hear it people to believe you're actually scared
yesterday? So, I was right. You were lying then about being scared
for your face to mute it because I'm going to talk about something
that's sensitive information that's not the gate code. It's just
the no. No, please. For the love of God. The love of God. Nick,
please don't say you're going to say something sensitive for
the sake of getting stream muted. Please. We talked about this.
This is the one thing we hammered out. This is the one thing
we actually hammered out. Please, for the love of God, Nick,
don't. think that you're I'm not sure if you're are you delusional
or did you think you were genuine I realize that he's actually
narcissistic and he was never going to take any advice. I do
understand that it's I'm making a it's it's just me joking that
like we literally walk through this. We did literally walk through
just we did literally walk through it, right?
I don't think so. You don't get to threaten me like that. Dude,
if you're going to do that, you know, I'm sorry this. I didn't
do anything to you. You accused me of being insincent and you
unmuted and you said it. No, you did say it. The security camera
has your footage saying it. Fine, but if there's no qualifier
there. What do you mean qualifier? You literally just made that
threat out of nowhere. So, you expect people to believe yesterday
that you were so scared for your safety, but then today you're
threatening to cancel security and the fence being built. That
doesn't make any sense. It worked for the day it stopped the
escalation.
So, see, you admit it. You lied. You weren't scared. No, I just
said it worked. It did exactly what it's supposed to do. Oh god.
Are we teaching Nick terms? We talked about escalating all the
time. Are we teaching him terms? Oh, no. It's learning. That
means that is good, but not in a good way. Sorry. Unlike you,
when I call in, this just seems like they both are trying to
out debate each
Yeah, he is tremendously autistic. Like in an unironic No, ironically,
he is tremendously He is No, he is tremendously autistic.
No, please don't call it autistic. It's not autistic at all.
Okay. Uh he is tremendously like logical when it should be an
emotional fight. He will be like actually you just said something
that is technically incorrect. That is like I don't know what
to call that. It's not autism. I guess it's something you Oh,
that's not true. You tried to act like I was armed inside the
house in a bathroom with a shotgun. I have never
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I heard this. Somebody brought
it up earlier. Did this actually happen? Because when he was
talking to the cops, I didn't think he said she has a gun. I
think he said, "We have weapons in the house, so you should just
come out." I think that's what he said. Like, there are weapons
in the house. They don't want you to be there. I didn't think
he said like, "Oh, she has a gun. Be careful."
something gun in this house because you were upstairs and you
refused to come out of the room. No, I said, "Let the cops come
up." He said, "Don't I don't know what he said because that's
what I said. Let Let He wanted you to come out. They always So,
because I told you that yelling at me, I Oh, their viewers just
spiked over a thousand. They're uh
y correct. I just heard come out and that's scary to me. I don't
think you could have called me from downstairs and this is not
debate pervetry really. They both genuinely get very upset in
these situations, right? I don't They don't separate emotionality
from anything. It's not true. Nick Nick gets really
Yes, but he still pedantic again. We're not reactive.
And like he'll say mean because it's like a and be explosive
and stuff. This is not like logical rational be pedanticish type
problem. This is like they're both actually upset.
All I'm saying is if he says pedantic he loses notable in the
discord automatically. Okay. Immediately he loses it. Let him
keep it for me. If he says this I will lose it. Stop. I would
have I would have because I knew the cops were downstairs and
Hold on. We got a We got a We got a We got another solid Nick
frame here for more memes in the future. Okay, this is a good
one. You love to see it. Get that in the Discord for you. I would
have. I would have cuz I knew the cops were supposed to come.
That's not true. You didn't try calling
No, I didn't say that. Ellie, have you ever sped out really hard
in a fit of rage? Yeah, but that's why I'm saying
is a lot of spuring and a lot of rage.
Okay. Could you just say I called you? Just called me calmly.
I didn't say I called you. Why are you saying I lied about that?
I never said I called. No, you you said you wouldn't have picked
up. I'm like, that's not true. Well, that's not a lie. That's
just my assumption. Why is that's wrong. I'm saying you could
have. Hold on. Nothing. No. I That's my assumption. What do you
mean? I know. [__]
Oh,
don't. Sorry. I got to go. I gotta wrong. I'm saying you could
have. We're watching. We're fully locked in. That's my assumption.
What do you mean? I know. I'm saying you wrong this. It's just
wrong. Okay. I'm saying that you could have. You had the ability
to. Again, there's times why you don't pick up. The point is
this. Okay. I I need you to mute it real fast. Otherwise, I'm
just going to go ahead and start doing it because you accuse
me of it. Mute it cuz I didn't say that. I'll say what I said.
We can watch the tape if you want.
He's like 70% Jojo posing. What do you think of that comment,
Kenny? Yeah, he was posing a lot. Yeah, kind of like that. Like
leaning back, right? Just like always leaning backwards kind
of
We're going to verify this. They didn't hear anything though.
I know, but we are going to watch the security. But they didn't
hear what I just said. Yeah, you just started talking about the
post now cuz I can show them the security that stop. You're gonna
tell chat that I'm lying, but you're not gonna let them hear
what I actually said. Because I can show them on security camera.
That doesn't make any sense. You I can literally show them what
you said. Literally, dude, you cut me off again towards that
because you're already lying. You're already rewrite. Yeah, I
don't think his issues are related to autis like I think there's
something else going on there, but he I think he has a one or
two tendencies. Wait, wait. What was Oh, no, wait, wait. What
was the line in the two words? Because you said I started with
I don't know if the post. That's a lot more than two words. Well,
you started talking about the postnup just now and you're acting
like you just said that right when you were threatening to cancel
security and that's not true. I I need I need you to pause it.
I'm going to I'm going to cancel the call right now. Like I need
you to mute it. No more threats. There we go. I'm not canceling
it again. You're threatening my safety. Nope. That's what you're
doing cuz I do not want to cancel my money. Let's talk financials
then. Okay.
You get the house in the post note. Do you still want it? Of
course I want that house. So you post not the whole thing. No,
that's not how that works. Well, then no. So then you don't want
to post. Not the way you wrote it for No. Wait, you're going
to rewrite. I want a lawyer. Wait, you're going to do it the
whole way? I want a lawyer with the postnup. Yes. No. No. That's
fine. I want a lawyer to talk about the postnup. You've always
had that right. Well, we're going to we are going to debate the
postnup with the lawyer then. No, we're not. Yeah, we you just
said I had that right. No, you can't. I don't have to do that.
Oh, that's fine. Like like you can take him to a lawyer and debate
it with him if you want to, but I don't give a like like but
I'll say this, okay? I would appreciate it if you Dude, but I'll
say this, okay? I would appreciate
it.
H, she's enjoying it too much now. Now, if you did
keep saying somebody had the smug ammo. That's the fact that
they have both got enjoyment out of this like insane type of
content that actually stresses me out should be like uh an indicator
that these people are not right in the head. What kind of food
you having, Kelly? What's on the menu today?
Um, sorry.
I'm literally asking. I'm just curious. Oh, I thought you were
just making a joke about me eating and you didn't really want
to know I was eating. I'm just eating like a cake thing.
Okay. And you're not sharing
it difficult.
I don't think you have read. Have you ever read? I know the Sparkos
version you told me. No, I didn't read. No, no, no, no. Did I
Did I hand you the actual thing? No, you held it when you were
with me. Such a liar. No, no. Say that again for everyone cuz
you're going to get [__] Videotape the whole thing,
Yeah, we're talking about beforehand when we discussed it at
home. First of all, I gave you a multi-paid copy of it. I asked
you, "What does this mean?" Cuz I don't understand how this That
is your own fault. That's not my own fault if you didn't explain
to me truthfully.
Cuz I don't You don't even Do you even remember what I said?
How How So you're accusing me of lying there?
Because I don't remember lying. Yeah, you lie enough now. I know
that you've been gaslighting me for years and lying for years.
I have reason to believe you would lie to me there. [__]
this. What I said was that we need to reflect the the monetary
split because I don't believe you're going to honor that like
in the post like that. Uh I don't think you deserve 50%. And
I think that you're just gaslighting and manipulating me and
and me into signing something and it's going to be great. All
right. Well, that's what you thought. You also thought I was
going to jail last night. That didn't happen. So, let's let's
try it. Nick,
you were so sure I was going to go to jail for six months. How
did that turn out? Yes, you did. to me. I have it on security
camera. Mhm. I never said 6 months. Yeah, you did. When you're
imagine like I'm going to go, you're going to go to jail. I'm
going to try to send you away for as long as possible. You're
going to be in cuffs tonight and you just ruin your life is what
you told me. Damn. So, let's try it. Sounds like something you
would say, George. This is just like
average Tuesday night of them. I don't know.
It seems to be the case. Yeah. Wednesday night. Wait, what day
is it? Hell, I have like
Shy above song. It's like average Tuesday night for Shia above.
Yeah, this average Wednesday night for Nick
cancelled it. No, muted thing. Last chance. Uh, no. Because you're
literally threatening my safety by trying to Nick. Nick, we talked
about it. Nick, please stop security on my property. Sorry. Uh,
I can message Dors, too. You have no power, your [__]
Well, I can ask them to escort him off if I have to. He has no
power here. Well, you're the one who is threatening my safety,
so I can have you escort him off. You are because uh the fence
is not open. I have been robbed recently, and you keep flexing
wealth and attracting people who want to
us. You can leave.
I'm not going to leave.
I mean, they both get instigating arguments about money, but
yeah, she specifically flexes slightly more, I would say, with
the watches.
But to be fair, that's just asking someone to nick a watch off
of Nick. Huh?
What do you mean flexes more with the watches? She? No, I said
he No, I said he specifically flexes with the watches. Oh, sorry.
We all heard she. Maybe because of the the cake. I don't think
she has any watches, does she? She does have a very expensive
watch. Actually, Rey might have seen it. I think Rey did see
it. Yeah, she had a crazy watch. The thing it was, oh, I remember
the IRI clip where he said it was like very distracting and everybody
was like, "Oh, no. You're talking about her." I felt the exact
same way. Her watch
was just insane. I don't know how it was like a void. I had to
look at it. I don't know what what really weird
and you know that exists but she wasn't flexing it.
No, she wasn't wasn't flexing the watch.
Who flexes who flexes more, Kelly? I thought you were saying
Nick. At first I thought you were saying ammo. Then I thought
you were saying Nick. No, I didn't say I I was unaware she flexed
that stuff at all. So now that I know that she also participates
in it, I can criticize her criticizing him for participating
in the same stuff. But they both shouldn't do it because they're
both they still do because that's all they have. They're vapid,
self-centered, self-interested people whose only interest is
money. So this is what you get. Wow. Kelly
one. Kelly one. Emirat zero. I thought that he was so scared
yesterday about having a troll call him.
I guess he wasn't that scared
then. Odd you get amaranth on tonight.
Um I don't know if that will happen. Yeah, I don't know.
Nick W. Wrong with y'all. My part is I wouldn't doubt that we
could get Nick on again though, to be honest with you.
tried to not give up on him for too many years. His problem is
he's insane.
What? I'm getting handed to cancel the [__] therapy
because I'm sure you agree. We're just wasting money. I don't
Oh, here. We're back to where we were. Let's go. If you want
to, I can't control you, Nick. You're the one who blew up on
me today. I was fine. I was chilling.
Look, I controlled myself this time. Okay. I didn't say it. My
position is very simple. If you want to let me finish, I can
say it. Sure. Go for it. We're going like this. Okay. You are
being really weird on this whole fake corion thing, right? That's
fine. Obviously, that's your right, right? Here's the thing,
though. Right. The whole reason you even get this house is because
of the post. If that didn't happen, that's not necessarily the
case. You understand that?
Okay. Well, so then if you are getting the house in the post
and you're getting all the cost of the renovation that are still
ongoing, then it needs to reflect that. You don't even want this
house multiple times. Is that that's great? But like what I said,
address it, dude. It's un Oh man, it's so crazy cuz like he he
probably does know a little bit about numbers and stuff. Like
he would know if if you asked him questions around this, you
could easily get him to go, "Well, yeah, okay, that's a good
point. Yeah, okay, this isn't true." But like in his mind right
now, he actually thinks he's making like co coherent arguments
and it's just not happening at all. Obviously then the value
of the renovation need to be reflected, right?
That's to your benefit. That's your benefit. I know. I agree.
Yeah, no problem with that. Right. Great. But all of that is
only true with the post note. And so when you sit here and you
accuse me of cheating you while I'm just giving you free money
in the intro. No, I'm telling you the cheating me part is trying
to take 50% of all my ongoing earnings AR going forward. Yeah.
And that was emotionally coerced out of me in order for you to
stop leveraging my horses. How the So you're saying this is Okay.
No, no. Say it with your full chest here. You're saying that
to get that by line of the post number I directly threatened
your horses. I'm gonna talk I'm gonna have a lawyer talk to you
about that one.
Got him. No, you didn't get anything. I'm saying my lawyer will
I'm going to bed.
Okay. I'll talk to you later. Trying to fix the multi-millionaire
people and really appreciate it.
Hopefully we can completely ignore everything again. But yeah,
we'll see.
Good night. Uh, good luck. Surely they'll give you a crumb afterwards.
All right. Uh, we'll see.
I'm doing it for I feel like I almost certainly I almost certainly
earned Amarad some money with that stream. So, I should get a
percentage. Okay. No, I think so. Hey,
wrestle openly about everything and then Hey, guess what?
I've got lawyers and I already No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no. Kelly means money. Kelly means money. Kelly 100%
means money there. Do not do not think she was implying something
else. That's literally all she meant.
How you like that? Did you really? I don't know. Why don't you
go find out? Why Why are you constantly lying now? Um, it's You
don't know if it's a lie. I know it's a lie. You do? Yes. Okay.
Sorry. I'm doing some emote updates right now. Give me a second.
You do?
So, what did you do? Get someone to go file on your behalf?
I'll never tell you. You'll have to go find out. Left the property.
You have to go find out. You haven't left the property. You can
talk to my lawyer at this point. You don't have one yet. That's
what you think. You're right. I don't have one. I have multiple.
If that's actually what you're saying, I'll call one right now.
So, you want to do that? I I don't care what you do. No, I'm
saying like if you want to keep lying about it, I'm just going
to have to do that. Did you or did you not? Cuz I haven't. No,
I did. You didn't? Yeah. You actually did. Yeah. When? I'm not
going to tell you when.
So, why'd you do that while while while having a quick therapy?
Because I could always cancel it, right?
You I could always choose not to act on it, couldn't I? But you
won't turn over a new leaf. So, um, so wait, wait, hold on. Your
thing is that um, especially after we talked about this today,
right? That's the craziest part. We We talked about this today.
Okay. Um, I was like, "Look, if either of us kind of lawyer up,
let's just let the other one know." And you agreed. You already
said that after I did it, though. So, you said that after I did
it. What am I going to do? Tell me. No, I'm to let give you the
chance to turn over new leaf.
What the [__] Wow. That's a one-size
thing. So, let me ask you something. Is your lawyer telling you
it's unfair then? Because that should probably me. I'm not going
to tell you.
Well, that's a real easy one to work through. If he didn't tell
you because if he did, you would think you didn't talk to my
lawyer at this point. If he did, you would say you can talk to
my lawyer back because he didn't.
So, hold on. Nick is basically or Emran's basically saying she
did get a lawyer. The lawyer is like making things happen in
the background and he's been unaware the whole time. You didn't.
And I don't think you even got a lawyer. I guess you can think
what you
want. Did you alone do this? Cuz
rewind. Is nobody else watching? What? Just tell me what happened.
She lawyered up. That's the only thing that happened.
She didn't have a lawyer when she first signed it. Why is Nick
so in shock if it's fair? I don't think I understand. Once the
lawyer She's had a lawyer for a little while. That's what it
is. I see. Like, and so if I really have to, I can message mine
right now. But like if you did it, you tell me. Also, you have
one, too. I I don't have one. I I say I have to message one right
now. Like you said message mine right now as if you have one
right now. Like the one I'm going to hire. Oh, okay. Talk to
the lawyer then. Go for it. Go for it. So you actually want to
get the process started. Retainers and everything. You can talk
to this point because if you did, you can talk to my lawyer at
this point. If you did, you would have already paid a retainer
and for the work you paid for. You can talk to my lawyer. You
didn't. You can talk to my lawyer. You absolutely didn't. You
can talk to my lawyer. Talk to my lawyer. dumb that you're lying
about this. You can talk to my lawyer.
Anyways, cancel other things. He's kind of him right now. I ain't
going to lie.
It's uh it's not great. Okay. It gets worse when you realize
this guy like kind of idolizes Andrew Tate in a lot of ways.
Like I don't think Tate would put up with
this. No, I don't think so. He needs to
uh get a bunch of chicks or whatever and make him a bunch of
money and then traffic some of them. To be fair, he's made a
lot of money off of one chick.
Like a lot.
Is that if you actually had talked a lawyer unless he's not in
jail. Purely spiteful. You wouldn't be acting like it's up there.
Like like I that's how I know for sure you you can talk to my
lawyer.
You don't have one though. So I'm talking to you. Nope.
I do have one.
You're going to have one? Sure. I already have one.
I mean, what do you think that's going to do? Get a rise out
of me? No. I'm just telling you talk to my lawyer.
I You You already got a You're rising yourself. Okay. I'm not
trying to get a rise out of you. I'm just letting know you can
talk to my lawyer cuz you keep threatening my security. So your
new leave. Whoa, whoa, whoa. That's your words. I would say you
threatened my security. You're the one threatening. You're the
one who's trying to cancel security actively to try to cancel
the game. Anonymous just $10.
I love the audio engineering on this stream. It is so great.
Thank you. Damn, huh? This sucker got played. That was a beautiful
reveal. for someone who was just scared about your security yesterday
from somebody troll calling you during the day and now So why
does it matter? And so now at night you're trying to threaten
the security when I actually do want security. So why does it
matter? Yeah, I'm not scared during the day. I'm scared during
the night. Do you want to hear the craziest thing that I learned?
Oh, because of how communal property works. Okay, never mind.
Literally, I can go to your stream right now on the desktop and
turn it on. For a second, I thought I shut KCIP off instead of
turning multiream on, but I didn't. We're fine. That would have
been very disappointing. Own. You can go for it. You can stream
if you want. Goes live. I don't care. Still broke anyway.
We 2x here. 75736. We're going to have to go back to our VOD.
75736. And then we can speed it up a little bit. 737 during the
night.
Right here. Let's go. Let's speed up a little bit.
Nick, go live. Get on the stream. Realize that like you're posturing
because your chat looks like a couple of maybe a thousand people.
Um, and at that rate, like I think it's stupid to literally cuz
you realize if I get a lawyer, I pay retainer, right? And then
you have lawyer. Now we both pay retainers. So you're going to
throw 20,000 to entertain a chat. I'm not entertaining my chat.
So then that is maybe the worst argument he's made yet. Hey,
you getting legal representation right now for this contract
that you think was dodgy and for our impending divorce, that
would be really expensive for you. I think you should just let
me run the divorce. I don't what you have actually engaged with
a lawyer previous to today. Yes.
Okay. And so then why have you not said anything? Because I've
given you the chance over new leaf.
Whoa, wait, wait. Just cuz someone files doesn't mean they have
to go through with it. I don't think you
I do not think you understand.
No, I don't. Kick chat totally frozen right now. If you are unable
to type in the kick chat, you can go over to the Twitch chat.
Okay. The Twitch chat. twitch.tv/jdk with an underscore. I think
you understand. Chat works fine there. Just because I have file
doesn't mean that I have to go through with it. I don't have
to serve you. All right. I understand all that. Good luck, guys.
Um, but you realize the filing will be there, right? But you
wouldn't have known about it until you go do it yourself. saying
we would do therapy if it worked and then this thing comes to
60 days. You would just never say it. That's right. That appreciation.
No, it's giving you the chance for a new leaf. Like you kept
saying that you would. That really should be true. Well, I think
you're for not turning over the new leaf. You would not and I
already know the No, if I
would never do the things that you you've done to me. No, you
you're right. But I would also never give a guy hand in a parking
lot either. I would I didn't do that either, Nick. But I think
that you might to be honest. You seem like the type. I literally
watched you. You did not. Oh, Jesus Christ.
Oh my
Uh Really, did you see the first night where he started talking
about this?
Oh, every time he mentioned the guy, he'd just say random black
guys. You just keep tri random black guys. It was uh it was pretty
sus. Okay. Pretty sus. That's pretty That's pretty nice. Watch
me. You drove up from a distance and saw my sleeves at my side
and assume and y'all were still there. My hands were at my chest.
You saw nothing. You actually show us the proof. Show us the
clip. Show us the video. Show us the picture. Show me the proof.
Show me the proof. Show me the proof. Show us the proof. You
said you have a video. Show it to us. Why can't you show it to
us? Why can't you show it?
Uh little little bit of a leak. I was authorized to say this
during the conversation. I just don't know if I did. Um Amaran
shared some DMs with me. The thing she was most angry about when
Nick went to the Pearl show was that Nick was threatening to
keep or Nick basically was continued to sort of not say that
the cheating story was fake. That actually bothered her a lot,
right? That that Nick continued to say that she cheated on him
or she gave somebody uh what do you call it? Um like uh like
a hand job that she gave some random dude a hand job in Chinatown.
that that was what was upsetting her was she was he didn't like
dispel that that fiction on Pearl's show and she was very upset
about that and she did mention that like I think she said something
along the lines of like okay
uh good luck explaining to like your family why you don't why
they don't see Kate anymore based on you going on this podcast
right so she wasn't threatening the kids or anything like that
it was just like I'm going to be done with you probably not going
to be around your family kind of thing which is not it's like
a threat or whatever I guess but it's not quite the same as what
he was describing describing there. If you don't remember, he's
describing her like threatening to stop paying for her niece's
pony or something to threaten my life. Well, I did not. Show
us the proof. Show us. Show us the videos of these accusations.
Show it. You got her proof. I video a video. You said you had
one earlier. Show us the video. I'm going to show video at. Okay,
great. I'm not scared cuz I know it's so show ahead. Why? Unless
you deep fake. You going to go make one on deep fake and AI?
The video is [__] I'm happy.
I know accus
Sure. But for the public opinion already thinks that I'm a because
I have an only fans and you actively they don't know you're jack
off. That's not even true. But they would think that that's if
they think that I'm only they would say of course you jack off.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Spin a razor scooter into
my shin so I can feel something again. And Nick Small PE son
of spin a razor scooter into my shin so I can feel something.
I know cuz you're lying. Can you stop turning the Can you stop
by fixing the camera with me? Sure. I'll face it out myself.
I'm going to ask you one more time to stop that. I'm facing out
myself now. So I'm going to move here and not mute it. I'm facing
out myself.
Don't come near me. I'm not near you at all, buddy. You are near
me. Can you please back up? I think feel like you're too near
me. Please back up. Not in front of camera. Okay. Well, I'm so
at my face. Please back up. So then please back Why aren't you
backing up? Can you please? I feel threatened right now. You
are above me. That's fine. Okay. She feels threatened. I'm going
to I'm going to go ahead and end the Twitch stream. I didn't
realize we're almost 5 hours into the stream right now, guys.
We're going to go kick exclusive for the last 3 hours of the
stream or so. Okay. Three, four. I don't know how long we're
going to stream for, actually. I'll have to check donos and stuff.
But yeah, for the last two hours at minimum, we're going to go
to kick only. All right. Kick only. Hopefully it holds up. Hopefully
hopefully it holds up. Hopefully it stops like necessarily.
But yeah, head over to Kick, guys. We're gonna stop the Twitch
stream. I love everybody in the Twitch chat. But unfortunately,
I make double the money if you all go over to kick instead. Still
live
here. In. And yes. And 70 minutes. Okay, guys. So, I'm I'm giving
you time giving you all the time in the world to run over to
kick.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. We'll see you in just a second.
Twitch stream's going off now.
Bye-bye.
Wow. So, Kick is running a contest for most watch time right
now. That's the real reason for this drama at JSTOK. They're
running a contest for most watch time. What? I had no idea. Why
was I not informed? Not before I point the camera. Okay. Well,
I'm so my face. Please back up. So then, please back Why aren't
you backing up? Can you please? I feel threatened right now.
You are above me. That's fine. You are standing above me. Your
feelings are valid, but they're not real.
I'm not standing above you. I'm
Hey, and they said we couldn't help this guy grow. He just yelled,
"Your feelings are valid, but they're not
real." That's like one of four to five pointers. Damn it. You're
sitting. Yeah, I bet you go sit down then.
Darius is streaming Destiny Abby DMs. He's just Yeah. Uh Darius
is like a complete
So many such cases. Many such cases. Well, I don't want to [__]
with you. Like like listen, just point away from me and and if
you I will point if you if you if you speak that way. Sure. I
will go wherever you want. Great. Go sit down
Sit down because it's less threatening to me. I'm not even close
to Darius content. I mean, Darius is literally just explicitly
like trying to slander somebody or a criminal. Um, I'm I'm just
really not I I I understand some people might want to go watch
on principal. I'm just going to keep watching this. I know, but
sit down because you can still motion. Get over here really fast.
Please sit down. You said here real fast. I said please. I said
please sit down. Weird, dude. You're saying weird. I'm not asking
you to please sit down is not weird at all. You're weird for
refusing to again. Thank god we're on kick. Darius, please buy
a gun. Please buy a gun. Please buy a gun. Thank you. I was already
standing here and I like standing. I know. You said to go wherever
I want if I don't point the camera at you and I get $10 off.
No, he didn't. He faked that.
Welcome soap box.
You really decided today after that not to tell me if this is
real real cuz I haven't done anything yet. So Nick is turn I
try to Nick is quite upset that she's engaged a lawyer apparently
days ago and she's just revealing now to him that she's engaged
a lawyer organically. You never do it though. You never do it.
You just keep being a buttthead.
So my question is this. Why did you take the longer way?
Because every time that we talk about divorce, you say you're
on. Why don't we just go? Because I don't want to be in a car
with you alone. There
I when I've suggested that before, you said I have. Whoa. I see
Bob with the five gifted. Let's Thank you very much. She said
on stream she was getting a lawyer. Yeah, but that's different
from actually retaining a lawyer. Yes, she said she was, but
uh Icy Bob 90, thank you very much for the five gifted. Let's
go. Let's go. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you. You have never
I have and you said no. You've never suggested that. I have and
you have said no before. You've never suggested that. I have
absolutely. That's fine. No, this is great. But like,
let me ask you this, sir. If I had to think, you probably did
it when you first started signing contracts. Wait, there's a
Kitcon?
Almost certain. You'll never know. You're not going. I mean,
I can figure I'm not going. I'm not. I made no plans to go. I
don't know about it.
Okay, buddy.
You realize that like all these secret things that you do like
they doomed all of it to failure. Now I hear about Oh no, you're
doing it. That's absolutely true. You've done this yourself,
Anakin.
Oh no, she quitted Star Wars again. She quoted Obi-Wan yesterday.
No. Oh, wait. Is it It's not the same Obi-Wan quote, though,
right? I think she did a I thought she did an episode 4 Obi-Wan
quote and then that's like an episode 3 Obi-Wan quote. Oh, boy.
And yet all the dust is Oh, boy.
You're not coming out on top.
You're absolutely not. All right, that's okay. I've been You
know who wicked is that? Uh, what?
You know who Supreme is? He bothered me. Oh, never heard of him.
He's bothering me that he DM'd you
Oh. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Hold
on. Invite. Invite. Invite. Invite. This
one.
Okay. Hold on. Well, hold on a second. Hello. How's it going?
Do you know who I am?
Never heard of this guy.
What's up? Okay. Uh, Supreme is a prolific amaranth and Nick
and Joyer, by the way. So, he doesn't even need to get caught
up. He's He's seen enough. Yeah. I'm up to speed. Boring. Start
doing I think you need to actually start taking care of your
animals. So, I'm also going to cancel the other dog person. See,
you just I mean, that's fine. Sure. Whatever. I can literally
just talk to
Definitely not another example of like a borderline abusive threat
at all. Sorry, did you just miss that, Supreme? I just heard
somebody join the presentation or you have the stream on. Yeah,
I'm I I'm not getting sound through your presentation, so you
just don't pay. Don't worry about me. I'll let me get it figured
out. Hold on. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Wait, I'll figure
it out. No, no, no. I don't think it's you. Okay. All right.
I'm hearing But yeah, so she did just say that or Nick did just
say um and just because of this I'm like I'm gonna cancel the
second dog person too. I think you should actually take care
of your own animals which is you know cool cool. So I'm also
going to cancel the other dog person. See you just I mean that's
fine. Sure. Whatever. I can literally just talk to them tomorrow,
right? And I can escort them off the property uh with police.
So like you know they're not going to come back. So I can say
you're neglecting the animals then. You're trying to prevent
me from having help to take care of my animals. You were actively
neglecting them. So, checkmate, [__] Checkmate. Say
whatever you want. I'm still
You're going to just These two need to not be under the same
roof.
Nick needs to get a hotel. They need to communicate via lawyer
only. It like it's over. They need to be thinking about like
their next steps moving forward. They need to not be in the same
together. I am legitimately actually concerned about this turning
into violence like um or or something. Somebody's they're going
to do something that they regret. They're going to say something.
Someone's gonna break something. Someone's going to de like they're
already divulging that they shouldn't be divulging. Yeah. I feel
like they've said nearly all of the things. I feel like there's
not much left to say. The the saying part has like reached its
zenith to me. And like that's why that's why I'm concerned is
cuz I feel like they've now they're like starting to second and
third time leak like very specific things about each other. It's
like okay, these are going to stop landing. And then how do you
escalate from there? You break [__] Somebody Yeah,
somebody is going to divulge their address, maybe their phone
number, maybe. Maybe one of them might accidentally get naked
on stream. It's going to get bad.
They're going to do something that they whole bit. He's doing
a whole bit. I didn't get it until the last one. Thank you for
making it obvious. Maybe flash theiring ass like mult bunch of
times, then, you know, recognize later what they've done.
Wow. Wow. Could you imagine the next six months? That sounds
Oh my god. I've been begging to do them for years. So that's
fine with me. That doesn't hurt me in any way.
It just that her saying that as a white woman just really take
care of my animals. You are actively neglecting them. So checkmate,
[__] Checkmate.
Say whatever you want. I'm still
You're just going to do animal chores for the next six months.
That sounds Oh my god. I've been begging to do them for years.
So that's fine with me. That doesn't hurt me in any way. Keep
making me money.
Wow. Oh, are you Oh, that's You know, I hadn't heard that one
from him. That's pretty crazy, bro. Keep making you money. That's
what you said. How was I supposed to interpret that? Keep making
me money, girl.
The way that you said that. Oh, you're just digging yourself
a deeper hole, man. You really hate your life. God damn. Never
met a man who hates her life so much. You asked. You literally
asked, Nick, just go live before you just go live on your stream.
I I I Your incels want you to go live on your stream right now.
They said, "We miss you, daddy. Can you come live?
Kenny, she's talking about you right now. What? You know that,
right? How could she? You know, she's literally talking about
you right now, Ryan. No, he should go live though. Yeah, go live
on your stream. What are you trying to accomplish? I'm just trying
to say get away from me. I don't think I think we need to have
our lawyer talk to each other and that way. Thank you very much.
Well, I mean, you have plenty of lawyer friends. I'm sure that's
not how that works. I hope Well, you said you have a lawyer already
that you're planning to use. I didn't say that. I said I will
talk to my lawyer, meaning the one I hire. Okay, sure. All right.
Well, this has been very very fruitful then because at least
I don't have to wait 60 days while you scheme.
Okay.
If this this is going to be the silliest thing if you are lying.
That was the stupidest lie. You're right. If you are telling
the truth, you are stupid for giving up the advantage to me.
Giving up what advantage?
the fact that you would have
I mean it's already the wheels are already in motion. I don't
I don't know anything you if you act out now it's just clipping
yourself because I wouldn't talk to a lawyer. No, dumb dumb.
Make yourself look regressive. Cool. Got the elementary school
insults ready to go. Sorry. You're right. I'm I apologize. I
was I was pure cinema. It's Yeah. Unfortunately, she's starting
to farm a a little bit. And I mean, I feel like what other choice
does she have if every time she goes live, he's just going to
follow like her around. And like, well, she's telling him to
leave and he's tenaciously trying to like tooth and nail some
sort of victory, something that he can like rest his head on
and be like, "Yeah, I won today." I will say when he is not on
stream, she does just kind of talk about him. now, which is a
situation he put himself in by, you know, being pretty I I feel
like pretty easily verbally abusive to her, you know, unidirectionally
for quite a while. But now she just like talks about him and
now I I totally understand how he's like probably losing it.
He should still leave. Absolutely. I just I feel like 1% empathy
here where I'm like, okay, it's uh Yeah, I understand why it
sucks. It's still a bad look for him to constantly be walking
onto her stream to talk though. If you're in a marriage and your
significant other, your spouse is talking about you like to the
to the whole world constantly, what you should do is say that
is that's like not the kind of relationship I want to be in and
so I'm going to leave it. That's what you should do. That's what
a confident highv value man would do would not be to sit and
argue tenaciously hoping that he can have like, you know, some
some small victory uh to to fuel his confidence or something
like that. No, you're going to handle your business. You're going
to say only what you need to say. You're going to walk away and
do something else that provides value to society because you're
a high value man. No. Well, I think we know that that is absolutely
the last thing he has on his mind in the world. I think that
is there. That thought has not entered his head whatsoever. But
be a good boy and take a please go live. Please go live. I I
will go live. But uh you just said okay. Why don't you do this
over there? It's good content. Go do where? What? Whatever you're
looking up on your phone on your stream and just narrate the
whole process. Good content, dude. You can literally do a divorce
meta. Woohoo. Did you? No, I did not. No, you don't have to call
them right now. I'm saying you're looking I'm going to stream
the email. Same thing said just dump. Well, let me not show it
obviously, but you can talk to your chat and narrate your thought
process. I will. I just need to go across, but I'm going to squeeze
off a few emails first. Okay. Squeeze them off. Squeeze them
off. I feel like every time she starts to do this, starts to
like smile and start to giggle, he actually starts losing it
again. Like over again. Yeah. Yeah. Time. Like she has this crazy
laugh that gives her PT. Yes. I'm not going to tell you. You
can talk to my lawyer. Why is that a negative? I'm not going
to tell you anything. You can talk to my lawyer. You're so [__]
hate hearing him get close too. That's like making me nervous
now. Her smile starts to disappear too when he does.
I'm not going to tell you. You can talk to Okay, sounds like
you are blah blah blah. I don't think it's I don't think he has
it in him to like hit her or anything, but I guess anybody can
be pushed. I don't think Yeah, it's like the it is the pushing
where like I don't think when he says he's never been physically
abusive, I like believe that 100%. Right. But um yeah, I I feel
like he's he's starting to run up. When you when you have somebody
who is abusive and then they realize that who's verbally abusive,
maybe this is Man, I don't know if I I wonder if if you could
say that somebody's verbally abusive, if their words stop meaning
anything to the other person, like if they would go to some other
form of if they need to see the reaction of the person being
like scared or hurt, like will they will would they escalate
to something physical eventually, right? Once um once the verbal
stuff stops getting an effect. Have you ever been in like a work
situation or roommate situation or significant other situation
or like parent situation where it's just like hatred and you're
stuck under the same roof or place of business or what have you
for like some number of hours a day you're just like stuck with
these people or this person. Okay. I had a nightmare roommate
if you have to think about it. You haven't other than stuff but
it's like that wasn't real. Right. Right. Right. Right. Yeah.
Especially when you're an adult. I had like a nightmare room
roommate situation and dude like uh and I had like a nightmare
boss situation one time uh in like my mid20s and like both both
situations it's just the worst situation to be in. It's like
living in a prison honestly. It's like being in a prison like
you have nothing to do. You're just like spinning in this centrifuge
and you're just spiraling in this like and seething in hatred
and you know it pushes you to do things and say things that you
wouldn't do otherwise. That's what I mean. They just need to
get out from the same roof of each other. That's it. Go ahead,
vent your grievances, you know, aside, you know, on your own
or whatever independently, but would be healthy. All right. You
know what's the craziest part? I bet you probably checked my
email, so you know, I didn't reach out. No, I didn't bother doing
that. I just felt like you're being crazy lately. And it turns
out that you hadn't filed, so that's fine. Well, I never said
I did. I know. But the lawyers left the lawyers. What are you
talking about? Don't worry about it. You can talk about the lawyer.
You're saying You're saying I said I filed. No, I didn't say
that at all. Well, then why would you say that I had You said
the lawyers confirmed. Isn't that a good thing? I I don't even
know if it's good or bad. I'm just telling you that I filed.
So, you confirmed I didn't file and then you file. Oh, they kind
of just did at the same time. You asked them to though. I'm not
You can talk to my lawyer. You were so You're supposed to say
yes because otherwise it's like what you talk to my lawyer. Okay.
Well, tell me with your lawyer. I'm not going to tell you. Never.
Oh, I'm sure they'll be in touch. I haven't gotten a lawyer yet.
Well, yeah, I know they'll be in touch. You know what the funniest
thing is? It's that they will be in touch, but like mine don't
have to do anything because unless you're challenging the post
note, it's already done. It's just crazy how immediately go to
threatening the neglect of my dogs and then you'd want to act
like there's no coercion. I'm saying that you should be taking
care of yourself. Yeah, you can't. You wouldn't say I'm going
to I'm going to dismiss your help. That's crazy thing. Why should
she be doing herself? Well, they have all the money in the world.
Why? Um yeah, there's no reason. I think this is just like obviously
kind of borderline abusive behavior. Also, in that silent moment
there, I added a couple new emotes. Two new Xeno emotes. One
new one new ammo emote. Does this one work? Does this work? Yeah.
Okay. Boom. Boom, boom, boom. Well, there's not neglecting there.
You're just going to have to do it. But the fact that their lives
are more enriched with more people you take care of. I don't
have a problem with that. But the fact that you are without complaining
because you're complaining that's neglect because you can't have
help. Man, you're so pressed. You're so pressed. I am zero pressed
because zero pressed. Okay. Zero narcissistic as well, right?
I have you on this really good. Okay. Because And Nick won. He
has her honor really good. You've already talked to your lawyer.
I know, but you don't tell me who it is because you don't have
a lawyer yet. The problem is this. You've made a claim on your
stream. Two pack just tip $10. The 10 for the queen said talk
to my lawyer. Two pack just tip $10. The 10 for the queen said
talk to my lawyer cuz Nick's still crying like you owe him something.
Tell that boy it's too late. Tupac watching. That ain't how that
works. Pull chat up please. Uh oh. I think it is how it works
actually. I don't I can't really You can find out when my lawyer
contacts you. If you want to do that mute real fast, though.
No, I can't pop the chat out at all. I don't want Well, if I
say this, it's going to be real hard to take back uh that criminal
thing we're talking about for you, right? Let me read the statutes
again or what are you talking about? Well, that's what I'm saying.
I'll tell you real fast. It's fair. It's for your benefit. Just
I mean, look, if you want this one, I'll send it to you if you
want to, but like I I literally showed you the other day, but
I can do it again. You're going to want this information to show
your lawyer, right? Okay. If needed. Um well, I'm going to go
over there and confirm that. Oh, the fake mute. I'm pulling up.
What? Yo, Nick is getting farted. I don't think it's fair to
do that. I think that's fair to do. Yeah, I don't think so. Too
bad. You make your audio more like ammo so we can get four TTS
for the price of one. No, I'm afraid not. No, I don't think so.
I'm making sure that you can't take home for me. You'll have
to just decide you want to save her. I actually think this is
a good strategy from her though. I'm not going to mute so you
have to leave. You don't want to be on camera or on audio then
get the out. That's basically what she tried doing before and
then he leaked the gate code and it seemed like he was about
to leak [__] earlier. I don't know. It's kind of
rough.
No. Um, the rough you're nasty. No, no, you can talk to my lawyer.
On the couch. Okay. History of taking my phone on camera. That's
First of all, I'm not agreeing to that. I'm just saying like
the police have a record of that. It's fine. Like, you literally
stole my phone on camera as well. So, I I did not I did not snatch
phones out of your hand. One of the last it either. Texas is
one party. Unfortunately, when Amaran's live streaming, I don't
know that you can walk into a space where she's live streaming
and have that like hold up in court, right? Like it's not like
you're unaware privacy. Yeah. Like that's the big thing. Do you
have a reasonable expectation of privacy? You usually do in a
private residence, but probably not when you know your wife's
a live streamer. You run her stream. You've ran her like stream
for 10 years. You know exactly what's happening when she's live
streaming. And then you enter a room when she's like saying,
"Please don't come in here." Right? Like that. She's also saying,
"I am broadcasting. I am currently broadcasting. You are being
broadcast to the world. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. You didn't
have my name. It's community property. What do you mean? Yeah,
it is. It's my money, my house, and you have it in my studio
on my selfie stick. That one is dumb. Oh, the trust that we both
are on. Hello. Hello. Feel like this audio might actually be
really exciting for a considerable portion of her audience. Hey,
uh, I think I can hear you now. Emmo smothers you with a pillow
ASMR. Don't worry about mute. I'll just tell you. You can tell
the lawyer. You want to see this thing so you can show your lawyer?
See, [__] I'm sure they know all the laws. That's
not the point. I was just No, I don't want to hear it from you.
You can talk to my lawyer. There's two routes you can I don't
I don't want to hear it. You can talk to my lawyer. If I got
to go over there and [__] get on your own computer
to [__] I'm already on my computer.
I'm just just mute it. It's not for It's just something I would
prefer, but it's good for you too. Well, I don't believe you
cuz nothing that you've said so far has been good lately. Hearing
it? Nope. I don't want you to hear it. She's not. Keep it yourself.
Oh, also evil Johnny. True. Never mind. You said one party consent,
not two party. Yeah, I was not paying attention. Did he actually
leave?
Sounds like he walked away. Let's chill and eat my food. You
could have kept the peace and instead you decided to be a When
I said that like the police said, he looked What's that Kenny?
Is her food code now? Uh, it almost certainly must be, right,
dude. Oh god. That means Nick might have to come back and chew
it for
She started. She's evolved. She's upgraded. She chews now. Like
for real. That was crazy. No.
Oh, thank god she did not lick the spoon off this time. this
like slow seductive licking off of the spoon, but it looked like,
you know, why is she staring straight in the camera? Just look
at what you're doing. It's not much better. Watch the wheel.
Watch the road. And the surfing. Oh god, dude. I was wondering.
I wonder how much of her insane streaming hours have just been
propelled all these years by it being maybe.
Yeah. Uh, hold on. I said I was up to speed, but I really only,
you know, I certainly haven't been as needy as you've been. This
guy's obsessed every day. I am obsessed with everybody. Yes.
Yes. Okay. Now I look in the sidebar at 1.3K viewers. I feel
like stuff's going on still. So whatever happens here, let's
start speeding forward. Funny because it's like now he's going
to let me take your Let's speak. I am. It's funny cuz it's like
now he's going to let me take your man. Oh no, she's talking
to that long time ago. We had a lot more days of going to do
a quick restart, guys, so that we get forward on the VOD or whatever.
Okay, with the end of the VOD forward, we're going to do some
skipping. Okay, we're aggressively chasing. Oh my god. Now it's
eating time again. We have to watch contractually obligated trying
to be a decent human when doesn't know how to do that in return.
I don't know if I can watch this. Yeah, bro. It's like this is
this guy lost it. Can we just skip to Nick? I've already I've
already said if she runs a mukbang channel, she'll actually make
it to the top of Only Fans again. Nick's been talking about how
she's been sliding off. She starts a mukbang channel. That's
a 2 million sub channel. I don't know why. And I don't know why
I feel so dirty watching her eat. I feel like I need to call
my parents. There's just something about it. It's not right.
Anybody when you're eating a food that's slurping, it just gets
into your ear and just gets into my brain. I'm like, "Please
stop the slurping. Please." I should I should tell you. I'm muting
this presentation until next back on. Okay. Is this a thing people
just like eat food for like an hour? I have always envied people
who can like take their time and eat food. I'm just always rushing
it down. It's such a bad habit. She's uh she is like I I don't
know. I almost wonder if she knows that it's like a meme. Wow.
Really? Looking at the camera, you don't think she knows? Hold
on. We missed something there. Missed some bread stick action.
Got to get that in there for Kenny. You didn't want to miss it.
Wait, how do they do that? Why is she slurping a bread stick?
Wait, why? Why is she slurping a bread stick? Can somebody She
just slurped a bread stick. I know. She dipped it. It didn't
have that much liquid. Yeah. I don't know how they do. I think
they just send you a bunch of bread sticks. I'm too emotionally
supportive of people. That wasn't a literal question, was it?
Never mind. You go help a nice man with these children. Here's
what else I want to know. Who the [__] in her life
has been telling her to like try and work it out with her marriage
all these years? Cuz I know that that's happening.
Probably her religious parents. I'm guessing it's got to be her
religious parents. I I would assume. Not even Christian. Just
change her denomination otherwise. No, not true, Ri. Not true.
It's okay. Shock know he's streaming right now. The abortion
got scary after being pistol whipped. It's whatever. That was
God being like, "Don't be a You're fine." He uh smacked me on
the head like Rafiti with Simba. It's the best. Don't let it
happen again. Pass can hurt, but she either can run from it or
learn from it. Might get both.
Had to do it. Had to do it. What was that? She's just She's literally
going to play the clip for us. Show you a new way. Peculiar,
don't you think? Yeah. Looks like the winds are changing. Change
is good. Yeah, but it's not easy. I know. By the way, she is
like a Disney adult. She like lives in Disney moments. Know what
I have to do, but going back means I'll have to face my past.
I've been running from it for so long. Ow. God, that was just
like when those three guys came in and tried to steal all our
crypto. It's haunting. Yeah.
Window into reality.
Yeah. Like roughly the same amount of tension, too. It's very
bizarre. Very bizarre. For sure. It still hurts. Oh yes, the
past can. But the way I see it, you can either run from it. Why
she does she keep playing it after the hit? I don't know.
Why she comp why she compare herself to the rightful king of
the kingdom? I mean like she's not a king. She's not doing like
she he just wants to say it's Nick. That's he just wants to say
Nick is Simba. Didn't Simba literally watch his father die? His
uncle like took over his kingdom. This some serious like Simba
actually went through something. Amran's a total Mary Sue. True
from God. You see? So what are you going to do first? I'm going
to take your stick. No, no, no, no, no. Not a stick. Hey, where
are you going? I'm going back.
Wow. Powerful. Yeah, that was the argument. Stickwack looked
like it hurt, but it's no outstretched arm before the robbery.
Remember he was trying to divorce me and I was still fighting
and trying to fighting his marriage, right? He revealed himself
light of the bedroom mirror in the closet light on his pants.
Made it look like his pants had pinstripes and he was like, "Oh,
huh, that's weird, the light." And I was like, "Wow, like a pimp."
Then he snickered and then I got hit with a with three times
with a pistol whip stick. Stop in the chat now. God was like
this going to leave this pimp. Hold on. Send in. Send in the
stick. Wait, is she saying Yeah. Well, kind of. God sent not
literally Rafiki, but Rafiki has a certain energy moving through
him and that's what's going on. This is ridiculous.
You get it? These are the people that people see it and don't
want to convert to Christianity. Bro, intellectual Christianity
is the only good kind. What do you think about in what what's
intellectual Christianity? Christologology actually reading the
Bible and the church fathers and understanding what they meant.
Now, this um I got him this kind of like God and God was telling
these guys to tell me. Am I crazy or is the Trinity not that
complicated? It's not. But if you want to facets of the same
hole, how do you not understand facets of the same hole? It's
very easy. And if you mess it up, if you mess it up a little
bit, it's a heresy. Explain the trinity. What's the trinity?
I uh there are multiple aspects of God. The father, the son,
the holy spirit. They are all God, but they are different aspects
of him because God as himself can do anything. But specific sorry,
God as himself is invaluable. So to die would be something would
be like a failing of some kind. So God himself as God cannot
die. So the son has to be created so it can be a man. So he can
be the perfect the perfect human. It's like a paradox. Okay.
Where's Jesus? Is he is he God? Is he a man? What is he? He's
the son. He's like the He's literally one of the facets. No,
wait. Is he Wait, is he human? Is he God or is he both? What
is he? He is He is both. He is He is a human that is like a facet
of God. He's both. Yeah. Yeah. So So is his mother Mary the mother
of God? No. Oh god. Who? This is like Warhammer lore for Southerners.
Who gives a [__] No. Mary is Mary is the mother of
God because Jesus is God. That's you just commit heresy. No.
Mary is Mary the mother of God. Look at who is God. So Mary is
the mother of God. Look it up. He's an aspect of God, but to
call him God is is to is to not understand how that aspect has
been formed. No, he is God. Jesus is God. I literally don't know.
I've literally never read this stuff. I' I've read like one minor
book on it. But it's just that to me the trinity seems like not
that complicated. It's like not that complex. That's that's all
people are like, "Oh, it's really complicated. You wouldn't get
it." It's like I'm pretty sure I would get it. I'm pretty sure
I could get it pretty easily. Anyway, you already failed. You
already failed with with not saying Mary is the mother of God
says. Okay. I read like three paragraphs on it. Okay. I read
like three paragraphs. You know what? I read three paragraphs.
I I felt like I got it. Second. You You failed the trinity.
Mhm. This
is so
I absolut absolutely in hospital in Africa. Wait, so is God the
bull and the robbers are so is Nick the stick. But then Scar
would have to be Mother Mary. That still leaves Nemo. Who's Nemo
in this? All right. I don't know, Ri. I've lost I've lost track
of the metaphors.
There's nothing.
I can't I don't Dude, I just I just laugh. I don't know what
it is. There's nothing even particularly funny. I just laughing.
Hard to watch. She's like I can feel her stress. I could feel
that this literally she's just like the camera is on her for
security.
And you know what? I think something that might actually save
Nick's heart is to have kids. But I don't want those kids. I
hope he after this he does find a girl to have kids with. I think
that might actually save him. Maybe. I hope he finds a woman
who's agreeable and doesn't care and knows that cuz some women
know how to pander to say the right things and then roll their
eyes and they look away just to live off the money. Some women
do that. And if that helps save his heart, great. Oh, agree.
I don't know how much I want to stick on this because I feel
like we are getting another fight between them. Yes, that's it.
She's getting back with him. Uh I So I have a hard time going
against the idea that she'll continue to be with him just based
on history, right? Like based on they've already had major blowups
kind of like probably close to on this level and they're still
together. I It's hard to fight against 10 years of history for
me even if you could see that he's abusive. So J the stream when
he comes back. Okay. Well, we could skip through all that and
just go. She's fueled up. Let's Let's skip. Let's go ahead. Well,
no, no, no. He's going to come back and she's going to mute.
So, we'll She's not fueled up. There's like half of that bowl
left. No. Oh, I can hear it from my bedroom. Confined. He live
yet. He's not live. Nick, go live. The good thing is all the
dogs now are in like this small confined garage and they'll be
loud if anyone if he tries them out loud and I can hear it. Oh,
we got one more new emote here. And there's a camera. Hold on.
Hold on. Let me let me get it. There we go. Let's go. Oh, have
I had my chat off stream the whole time? Security. He might be
in something. Yeah, chat's up. If you got in his car, long have
here. It's fine. He's probably watching called someone called
walked away. He does watch stream. Lately, it's just been like
a constant stream. God, please finish it. She went in a circle
and she's back to the and switch on a dime. It's crazy. I don't
know. The and the spoon gripping the bottom of the bowl. No way.
If you know people like this, they're abusers for sure. Like
this. Yeah. Take the spoons the bottom of the bowl and then slurp
it up. Jesus Christ. She's Is she doing it? No. She's going for
a walk again. Can you go back? Shoes on so I can go hang out
with doggos. Little dogos. Okay. Going to hang out with the dogs.
Me so I wouldn't be attached to him. I guess you're talking then.
What? What? That's when it broke.
bro. See, this is where I'm like, I made private tape. I made
this for my ex. My husband made me record this tape so he could
sell on his own for millions, but he pissed me off and I'm done
with his selfish BS. I'm sending it for $45 to show I'm better
off doing things my way. You're welcome. Am I taking this too
far? This amaran's only fans.
I don't know if it's fake. I I feel like they would farm this
no matter what. They would farm this. I I think they would farm
this no matter what. Unironically, they would farm it. You know
what I was thinking? I like the she's got whatever. I know people
were that it was a meme the [__] and bio thing, but
I feel like I get the feeling that it's literally like all that
stuff is Nick, which is fine if that's like the part of the business
that he manages or whatever, but like typing all that stuff,
it might just be that Nick has just literally complete control
over all that stuff. Could be. So, me I can't believe they're
farming this hard still. But then they took the days off, so
I don't even know. It's okay. Whenever you argue with me, you
always fit it in a suit and pacing like you're ready to leave
anyway. Just go. What's up, kid? That's based actually saying
there's no way back in the bowl again. You want to go? Just go.
Jesus. Remember, he had to squeeze out a few quick emails. He
did. I want to be worshiped like a god on this earth. But I wish
I had saved you so you wouldn't think that of me. It's like all
I got to say is, man, God must have some big plans for me. God
damn. This is crazy, right? This shit's crazy. Never seen a man
hate his life and throw it all away so much when he had when
he had it all. Must have got God God clearly has favored. And
I'm sorry you ain't it, boo boo. Jeez. That's a heresy. unfortunate
to have that personality type because man I mean it's not really
fair for her to say that like because it's it's obvious that
he's not getting his end of the bargain out of this marriage.
There's something about this marriage that he's not happy with.
He wants to be the man and like he wants the respect of being
number one, the alpha and the omega and he's not getting that.
I don't know if it's like this the whole like he's got everything
he wants. Why is he throwing it all away? Like he should he should
get to have the relationship he wants to but he needs to recognize
that he's just not going to get it with her. Please no no no.
I totally like I agree, but it's like I think everybody around
him is like you don't understand that that's just not worth it.
Like you have so much. It seems like such a trivial thing when
most men don't like think about it at all, right? I'd say well
it's something you only think about like it's like most people
don't think about being paralyzed, right? It's something you
only notice once it's a problem. But like it's not it's not like
a big deal. I think a lot of people look at him and they're like,
"Dude, you have like a hot wife. You have millions of dollars.
You're literally young. You're fit. What the more do you want
with life?" Right? He's like, I want my wife to like to literally
be waiting at the door when I get home from like a hard days
of work. Yeah. Yeah. And it's like which I don't even think it's
like the money doesn't mean anything. The money and the hotness
of of your significant other doesn't mean anything if you're
not getting like the most important thing you could want out
of a relationship contingent on the individual, which for him
it seems like being revered and, you know, more or less woripped
is like really important to him. But that's not you don't just
get that for free. like you have to earn that through your conduct
through like the fabric of your character. Yeah. Yeah. Um but
man, the thing is is like h and that's the that's the sad thing
is like he is just really like honestly the security is like
the biggest masculine thing I think right just literally being
secure in who you are. And I think that's the one thing he's
just seemingly not ever had. And it sucks because he's got man,
he's got he's got so many things. Like I feel like I could be
insecure sometimes, but if I had the money he has at the age
he is with like the Yeah. the the health he has and like all
of this. It's like dude, how are you not secure? How could you
possibly not be secure? I don't know. Me too, but I don't value
what he values this. I want my wife to listen to me. Who cares?
True. Stuff. I'll just take the money.
Give me one second.
I can pause. I'm listening to you guys, but I have to explain
something else. Years and years and years, and it's just like,
damn. All right. You want to throw your life away? I literally
can't control you at this point. I literally am putting my life
in danger to prevent you from throwing it away.
Huh? I did my best. I'm not a miracle worker. I ain't Jesus.
Oh my god. They're biblical reference. Jesus. You know, the guy
from the Bible. Everyone do a Bible study. He part of the Red
Sea. Hello. Yeah. Come on, people. sacrifice his son, right?
That's
Yeah, I know. It's just unfortunate. I did I did care for him,
right? Like part of me still does just cuz you've been with the
person for so long. But it's just I can't I can't keep living
like this. It's too stressful. It's too inauthentic and too stressful.
Is that going live? I assume he might go live after the cops
been talking to him. But no, the cop the cop is our uh security
guard. Off duty cop, our night guard. That's who he's talking
to. Not like not not an active duty cop. Counterpoint. I never
We have off duty cops as our security guards every night. Sorry.
Was there Was there more to that? I'm sorry. No, I'm just making
jokes. Okay. All right. I probably only need like robbery. Not
until like talked to somebody really quick about a couple things.
It wasn't even this rocky after the robbery. After the robbery
for the first like month or so, I was really good and stable
and then he pushed me away and said he wish he hadn't have saved
me. So then it all kind of uh I think it went from like 0 to
60 as far as [__] goes after that. Increasingly crazy.
Yeah. This is the worst it's been. Yeah. Like consistency. Maybe
not like the worst thing he's done to me, but consistency. Yes.
Of erratic extreme behavior. We had a second property and they
started renting it out. Even though he would never he would never
leave and go hang out there. He refuses to walk away, cool down.
It's part of self-esteem.
Listen, I'm worried for them to break down. I do. My blame is
if Nick leaves, someone's got to drive that 911 in their driveway.
Okay. And who better? Okay, buddy. Don't let it hang. Come on,
man. Better. What? What? I'm just saying the seals in that 911
are going to dry rot if it doesn't get run. Yeah, we should drive
it Supreme. I know a few people. Yeah. Okay. Doctor, play the
video, man. You're making it weird. I'm too authentic. And I
My mic was saying Never
Oh, my bad. Again, I'm too authentic. I don't authentic. I literally
I literally was just ripping with you guys over the Porsche thing
and I I had my mic muted. I'll be just give me two minutes. I
need to actually walk away for like 2 minutes. I'm so sorry.
Hit play. Betray my genuine feeling in my truth for the sake
of keeping a peep anymore. And I think that because your truth
part of the the robbery thing I feel like I thought she was rightwing
that she using words like a lot and it made me appreciate life
more. I don't feel like I should have to take a [__]
or be dishonest with myself. They just kind of like made me reprioritize
what's important. Whatever this like this is like too dragging
this just just slip from straight from the ball. I feel like
with with that bold technique you're if she didn't have all the
money she would probably have like a phone case and my I guess
my looping you can't have two. He started making very obvious
references and jokes and I think that's God talking through him
as a puppet and I pity the fool. God talk no Jesus. Listen got
to listen to the signs. He started being like I don't know if
I want you sucking my camera cuz you might think it's a snake
and that made me be like holy. Am I with the devil? I was like
wait hold on hold on. Am I with a spot of Satan? The did I just
hear? [__] But then like the robbery happened and
he's definitely not. I kind of ignored all the signs I was feeling
in the paranoia because I was in like I guess trauma bond mode.
But then he actively pushed me out of that mode all by himself.
And so then I've just been like, wait, maybe I was right. Hold
on. Let's step it back. Maybe maybe the robbery wasn't so much
him saving me. Maybe it was God showing me that I'm stronger
than I think I am and I got this and that I can save myself because
his aim is trash. H
huh. I thought Nick was bugging with the God stuff and I think
he's rectified now. What is this? So, all right. Tell me about
intellectual Christianity. How how did how does an intellectual
Christian feel about this? Like everything in my life is God
like micromanaging all the details of my life. Like how to be
nice to him. This is weird. I don't mean you're not Christianity
intellectually like a night and shiny armor and it was weird
to him. It's for everybody dumb. You feel like you didn't deserve
the behavior or I'm still trying to figure out why you would
push that feeling away if you're a narcissist and want to be
treated like a god. I don't It's so contradicting.
Nick got hooked on invent. That's why I just think like this
makes no sense to a new degree that I think that the escalation
intervention of God cuz this doesn't make sense. It's so brain
dead that this just has to be like the work of the Lord and I'm
sad that he's on the short end of that stick. Um but it is what
it is. Lord just comes up now. Where was the Lord over the few
years? This is this doesn't make sense. He's busy. Sometimes
you're lot sometimes you're his wife. You know other there's
other couples. Oh, you think she believes in a limited god? The
deist. The work of the lord is brain dead. It's not brain dead,
but why would he come up now? He's like omniresent. He'd always
be with you. He works in a mysterious ways. Oh my god. This is
just crazy. I just It's like write a book on how to ruin your
life. I don't know. But maybe maybe I guess Captain, you're right.
You're correct. I guess it's not really ruined though. If you
don't care about genuine love, if you don't care about being
loved genuinely by people because you're not capable of doing
it, then I guess it doesn't matter because you still have money.
I guess it's not correct. I guess if that's what you really love,
I guess it's not really ruining your life. It's just reentering
it in his situation. But but Catherine, I do think she's a deist
though. She's definitely not Christian because even this like
being Christian God does not work for you. God does show you
science that does help you specifically. I can't do that. I'm
a mammal. But if you want to be a lonely reptile, go for it.
Yeah, I already talked to the guard the other day about the current
situation. Catherine, I'm not I'm not a debater. I think after
I'm sure all the police talk about what happened yesterday, too.
I'm sure they're like, "And when is just going to get nighter
in here to give us his truth?" I'm sure it's been appointed.
That's who we need to hear from discussion. It's got to be next
on the in the hot seat. The hero we deserve. How long do you
feel lonely? If I didn't have animals, probably would or stream.
I feel more alone when it's just him and me in the room lately,
which is crazy. Like no dream. I don't It's not It's not for
me. I need the kick deal. It's up to Eddie. How do you feel about
Dobby is free now? Now that we've seen uh you know, we've gotten
a little more exposure into their personal lives. Yeah, I think
she's free. No, no. Do you think like cuz people were saying
like, "Oh, the Dobby is free thing is so cringe." Cuz she went
literally right back to the same
once he started being on stream and talking to my chat. He felt
like this is this is the turning point. I think the divorce is
the identity that he sees himself as. So then he had something
to prove and then he had to be better than me and then it became
a competition and then I became the thing holding him back somehow
rather than a puppet. I became his competition. It's like that's
worse than being a puppet of a narcissist being the rival. It's
weird. It's like he'll say to me like oh I just want to prove
it to myself but then he'll treat me like trash bragging about
how he wants to pass me up. And so I think like the talk of the
game just feeds into his men without him realizing it. He can't
separate like Captain from the actual person. When I said Dism
like there's no way you go only intervenes to help you. You know,
I'm just saying because I know that if you play a character for
12 hours a day, you're going to become that character. You know,
it's kind of like uh that episode of Grim or whatever where the
guy wore the mask too long and then became it got like attached
to his face. But for him, it happened so fast. Hello. Sorry.
Sorry about that, guys. I'm back. I'm back. I'm back. Oh, boy.
What did I Oh, I lost my headset. What you miss? She goes on
a whole rant on Nick on happening to Nick is divine intervention
is God telling her that she needs to get away from him. Are we
still in the Rafiki thing? All this time later, we're still on
our Rafiki moment. Hello. Yeah. No, we're we're still on the
how does God squeeze into the keyhole into every facet of my
life about like what he would do if he were me or like if he
were the streamer, not actually me for 10 years while I've been
streaming, you know, puppets master behind the puppet kind of
thing, pulling the strings. And so he's always like mad at me
cuz I No, that's not the case. Jesus and this is how you would
do this. The way you're supposed to say it in order to be successful,
blah blah blah blah blah. And so like he's been thinking about
it for so long and now that he had the chance to do it, it Oh
boy. How long until we get to more fighting and too much for
a narcissist to be able right after coming off of a god complex
of being a saving me? There's too many different psychological
factors at play and it's just eating him eating his brain. Cooked
overcooked and it's just like the game. I don't know if you guys
caught that. Different psychological factors at play and it's
just eating him eating his brain. Cooked overcooked and it's
stressful just like the game. Just like over a failing marriage